SURVIVING AND DOING IT WITH
NOBILITY.
>> THANK YOU.
GRATEFUL TO BE HERE.
>> Tucker: THANK YOU.
CANDICE OWENS WATCHING ALL OF
THIS.
HOSTED CANDICE OWENS PODCAST.
HAPPY TO HAVE HERE.
THIS VIDEOS MORE AND MORE
EXTREME.
THEY ARE NOT PERFORMANCES.
THEY ARE REAL.
WHY IS NO ONE SAYING ANYTHING
ABOUT THIS?
>> FIRST AND FOREMOST, YOU
MENTIONED KIM FOX IN CHICAGO.
SHE IS BOTH BLACK AND A FEMALE.
ALSO MAYOR BLACK AND FEMALE.
DIVERSITY AND EQUITY AND
INCLUSION AND FLUFFY WORDS
SUPPOSED TO MAKE YOU FEEL GOOD
BEFORE THE BAIT AND SWITCH.
INFERIOR ATING TO WATCH THE
MONOLOGUE.
MAKES ME THINK CRIMINALS ON THE
STREETS.
WORST CRIMINALS IN OFFICE.
THEY ARE VOTING ON PIECES OF
LEGISLATION HARMING THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
THEY DON'T CARE.
THEY HAVE ARMED GUARDS.
THEY LIVE BEHIND GATED
COMMUNITIES AND SOLD OUT THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
WE VOTED THESE PEOPLE INTO
OFFICE.
THESE ARE ELECTED OFFICIALS
STOOD ON A PLATFORM AND DEFUND
POLICE.
THEY HAD ARMED GUARDS THEY DON'T
CARE.
WE ALL SAW IT COMING.
YOU SPOKE ABOUT IT.
I SPOKE ABOUT IT.
BLACK LIVES MATTER.
WHO IS BEING HARMED THE MOST
WHEN YOU LOOK AT NUMBERS?
BLACK AMERICANS.
THE VERY PEOPLE THEY PURPORTED
TO HELP.
WE ARE GOING TO DEFUND THE
POLICE.
I WANT TO SAY TO PEOPLE WATCHING
STILL LIVING IN INNER
COMMUNITIES, DEMOCRAT CITIES:
GET OUT.
THIS IS NOT A JOKE.
DON'T WAIT FOR IT TO BE YOUR
CHILD YOU ARE PUSHING IN A
STROLLER WHEN YOU GET RUN OVER.
DON'T LET IT BE YOU ON A JOG
DOWN THE STREET AND GRABBED AND
KILLED LIKE WHAT PART TO ELIZA
FLETCHER.
RESCUE YOURSELF AND GET OUT